this is the most luxurious station wagon
that Czech car makers scooter has to
offer at boasts doodles of space plenty
of creature comforts and top quality
workmanship put all these qualities
together and the result should be
nothing less than superb contest and
Montes kirat explains that car maker
Skoda has rolled out the third
generation of its superb model now he's
going to test the new station wagon
version and decide if it lives up to its
name or if that's just false advertising
one aspect of the station wagon that's
if not superb at least above average is
the nineteen hundred and fifty litres of
luggage space that's a good 170 litres
more than a VW s Passat variate for
those who prefer to have a flat load
area when the rear seats are folded down
an optional variable floor is available
Skoda has come up with lots of clever
solutions for securing cargo like
barriers with velcro fasteners and hooks
there's even an LED flashlight at the
side the car we tested had the highest
trim level called the Lauren and
claimant edition
Matis points out that the materials
readily visible in the interior give a
high quality impression he describes the
workmanship as excellent but once he
looks under the dashboard or at the
center console and the doors the
materials quality seems to drop off a
bit though hardly enough to be worth
mentioning
that's this job
in general the design and workmanship
are first-rate and the controls are all
neatly and logically arranged
there are a number of good solutions for
stowage in front as well the door panel
can hold a one and a half liter bottle
while four half liter bottles can be
cooled inside the center armrest
the suburbs rear-seat with its center
armrest iPad holder and various power
connections is a little oasis of comfort
dual zone climate control and heated
seats are available on request and
another 60 euros will buy an additional
switch allowing passengers and back to
move the front passenger seat and give
themselves a little more legroom montes
is happy with the seats
he says the steering wheel sits well in
his hands and he can set the suspension
to comfort normal or sport using the
dynamic chassis control
he thinks it's very well tuned the car
we tested with the top equipment line
the 2 litre 110 kilowatts Evi engine and
a 6-speed manual transmission lists at
not quite 37 and a half thousand euros
in Germany even with all the luxury fuel
consumption is a pleasantly low 4.2
liters of diesel per hundred kilometers
Montes is a bit disappointed that the
2-liter 110 kilowatts Evo he tested was
still fairly sluggish at 16 to 1800 rpms
the suburbs body design includes lots of
straight horizontal and vertical lines
the hard edges and interplay of concave
and convex forms give the superb a
dynamic or a hectic look depending on
one's personal tastes
the taillights design also reveals a
fine attention to detail that may be
pleasing to the eye but is it superb
so pal that's what Montes wanted to know
is the Skoda Superb
really superb he thinks for the money
and the quality it definitely is and the
station wagon version maybe even more so